I'm gonna start a podcast sorry they're
not gonna start a podcast which I'm
really really excited about so myself
I'm actually a recruiter and I've had a
had a recruitment blog now for around
just over a year and a big part of my
blog is actually speaking and getting
other recruiters to sort of share their
experiences their learns their failures
what advice they give to those who are
thinking about getting into the industry
and what they tell themselves if they're
to go back three months into their
career and I'm someone who absolutely
loves listening to podcasts and I didn't
feel like there was much out there in
terms of the recruitment industry and
podcasts that's all really resonated
with me and where I could sort of
extract a lot of value from so what I've
decided to do is make a and start a
recruitment podcast which I'm really
excited about my blog is called the
recruitment rollercoaster because it's
exactly that and that's what I'm gonna
call the podcast it's gonna be the
recruitment rollercoaster podcast I'm
going to be using and that called anchor
to distribute the podcast and build my
episodes etc so I'll go through all that
and when I'm doing it to share it with
you guys but ultimately I wanted to
document the process podcast becoming
more and more popular now and they've
been around for a while so I think
there's probably a lot of people out
there thinking I'd love to start one or
how would I go starting one so I'm going
to be learning that along the way and
I'm going to be documenting the whole
time so this is the first of many videos
for my youtube and I'm really excited
about it so hopefully anyone that's
watching can take a bit away and learn
from my failures basically so I'm
looking forward to
[Music]